I don't care if 120 members of the state
legislature hate my guts I don't care if
the union thugs ate my guts I don't care
if two-thirds of the states my guts hi
I'm Tim Cavanaugh a reason TV we're here
with des Lak the Libertarian candidate
for governor of California Dale is one
of six candidates in this race the best
known of whom are Jerry Brown for the
Democrats and Meg Whitman for the
Republicans you're running for governor
as the Libertarian candidate have you
done any polling do you have any idea
where you stand right now in percentages
you threatening Meg I don't know about
threatening their polls out there that
show a large number of people want
somebody else but the polls don't really
ask who often the Republican Party will
complain that the libertarians are
drawing off votes and allowing the
Democrat to win what would you say to
somebody who takes that kind of argument
seriously and is saying this is not a
presidential election where the state's
already locked up and my vote doesn't
matter this is one where if i vote
third-party it actually could have a
consequence for me the problem with that
argument is we end up with people like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Meg Whitman
who are liberals they're not Republicans
they don't stand for what Republicans
claim to stand for Republicans often
campaign like libertarians and then when
they get elected they govern like
Democrats you have a proposal in your
platform to reduce spending to 1998
levels what may jo settle on 98 that was
before the latest criminal collusion
between Gray Davis and the public
employee unions where they increase the
pensions from two percent to three
percent and said it won't cost anything
we'll make it up at all in our
investment gains what do you think of
Governor Schwarzenegger 'he's effort to
rollback sb400 which was signed in 1999
by gray davis way too little way too
late i mean the fact is that even the
numbers that come out of calpers are
dishonest they have unreasonable
assumptions built into their estimates
of the deficits unbiased estimates of
the deficit in the
funding for public employee pensions is
about half a trillion dollars there is
no way the state of California will ever
be able to pay those amounts there need
to be some dramatic reductions not only
for new hires not only for current
people but for people who have already
retired let me ask you practically and
philosophically practically my
understanding is that if those those
contracts are in violet and even in
cases like Vallejo where the city went
bankrupt they ended up honoring the bulk
of these contracts and philosophically
isn't there some sanctity in a contract
no matter how screwy it is that
shouldn't be finagled with after the
fact the fact is the state doesn't have
the money the state of California under
our Constitution is a sovereign entity
and like any other banana republic and
that's how it's been run we can
repudiate our debt as a libertarian I
very strongly believe that people should
be forced to live up to their contracts
but I believe those union contracts were
entered into with what either is or
approaches criminal behavior on the part
of Gray Davis and the unions what are
some things that the average person in
California expects out of the government
that you would be willing to say no you
can't have that anymore it is an awful
lot of social welfare programs even make
Whitman says you know we've got a third
of the welfare recipients in the United
States and twelve percent of the
population our benefits are so generous
that we attract deadbeats from all over
the world including the other 49 states
another area a lot of Licensing and
regulatory agencies we license more
occupations in California than any other
state licensing doesn't keep us from
getting incompetent doctors and crooked
lawyers so you know why do we care if we
license somebody gives us a haircut a
lot of you know non libertarian types
without their would say yeah I'm not for
more welfare benefits and and certainly
you shouldn't have to get a license to
you know be a hairstylist but what about
stuff that a lot of people like a lot of
people like state parks
they like the roads to be in good
condition without having to pay a toll
what do you say to them first off the
roads aren't in good condition there's
huge amounts of gasoline taxes that are
diverted to other uses you want to use
the roads you pay gasoline taxes if you
want to use the parks you pay to use the
parks there's actually in a relatively
small percentage of the population that
uses these things so let that percentage
of the population pay for it your
platform contains a lot of attractive
material about getting rid of duplicate
of agencies rolling back a lot of the
regulatory agencies reducing the size of
the government employee payrolls how do
you expect to get that stuff done given
that nobody else has I think that nobody
else has really wanted to the line-item
veto is a very powerful tool the
governor has I'm not running for
governor so that everybody loves me I'm
running for governor to get the state's
fiscal house in order and I don't care
if 120 members of the state legislature
hate my guts I don't care if the union
thugs ate my guts I don't care if the
government employees hate my guts I
don't care if two-thirds of the state
aids my guts but the end of four years
when taxes are lower spendings lower
regulation is reduced and we've created
five million new jobs in the state of
California and our unemployment is three
and a half percent the run-of-the-mill
everyday taxpayer it's going to be very
happy do you think that's good campaign
slogan vote for Dale log then you'll
hate his guts maybe the longest part of
your platform is on immigration I should
congratulate you you just got John and
Ken's endorsement john and ken by the
way to extremely popular talk radio
hosts on KFI down here in LA and yet
your immigration proposals are a lot
less punitive than meg whitman's why do
you think that they went for you what I
offered was honesty and and I didn't try
to take two positions at the same time
philosophically I believe in free trade
in labor just like free trade in goods
and services we don't have an
immigration problem we have
a problem with the welfare system that
attracts people for all the freebies we
have we have laws that force hospitals
to provide care which basically makes
the health care worker slaves we have
the war on drugs which creates
tremendous profit opportunities for
organized crime we have idiotic foreign
policy that creates the Terrorism issue
in an ideal world if the government
government didn't control so much then
the only way people could come here from
other countries would be to be invited
by a citizen and sponsored by that
citizen if you come here and you
trespass you're a criminal what's the
magic element of being invited by
somebody why shouldn't I just you know
be living in Oaxaca and say hey I want
to start a hotel and so let me go up to
the United States and do it where it's
possible to do well if I've got the
money to do that and I can buy the
property or rent the property I don't
see a problem with that you come here
with money or skills you know you
contribute to our economy will happen if
you come just as a as a migrant worker
and say I'm going to trade my labor to
somebody who wants if there's somebody
that wants to pay for you then they can
bring you here you mentioned how many
how many people are collecting welfare
in California how big the state employee
roles are and yet it's a state with a
long history as sort of a maverick place
that weirdos like to come here and do
freakazoid things i don't think the
freakazoid population is big enough to
make much difference maybe suppose
perhaps i'm positive that the government
employees are a very strong voting bloc
they all have their own marching orders
from the union and they go to the polls
and like good little robots they pull
their you know levers for the democrats
to make sure they stay in there but it's
not big enough to sway the whole
election there's a lot of tax payers and
there's a lot of unemployed people who
want jobs and are saying you know this
is crazy
where are the new businesses we have a
bunch of pretty interesting initiatives
on the ballot this year the one that's
getting the most national attention is
prop 19 which would legalize and tax
cannabis where do you stand on that I'm
certainly going to vote for prop 19 I
strongly support it I prefer it not be
taxed but it's all about closing the
deficit isn't it right this is a I
prefer to close the deficit by reducing
spending do you view yourself as trying
to become governor or trying to get the
message out there well I'm doing both
there's a lot of people out there
they're just saying I'm tired of voting
for the lesser of two evils maybe it's a
long shot but even if it doesn't happen
that message is getting out there
you